I've always felt like you can learn a
lot about a man if he opens up his
jewelry box might be chokers tiaras
little ringlets in my case it's largely
watches I think by the time we've gone
through this arbitrary watch collection
of mine you'll know as much about me as
anybody on earth so let's begin I don't
know this is actually a found object I
was doing some scavenging with a folk
art buddy of mine and we wound up
working this into a living art piece all
that was uh was horseshit this is a
Jaeger this I wore an Iron Man 2 and it
has the open back that's a heck of a
watch probably my best watch I'm gonna
say this is an Omega
yeah that's an Omega that's a lovely
timepiece it's very sporty but I don't
have an endorsement for them so I'm
making second
this is a Rolex but it's kind of black
and shiny they can't go wrong with the
Rolex I can't I got myself and a buddy
of mine black Rolexes for his birthday
for some reason I guess I needed one too
this is the green money Rolex why do
they call the green I don't know I just
I saw an it's green and probably wasn't
cheap
that's Rolex
this was actually my grandfather's watch
and he'd hocked it to get enough dough
together to start a little pharmacy and
then he got busted for uh filling
scripts at that pharmacy for people who
were reforging their doctor's signature
so I mean really was a lot of shame on
this watch but uh I got it for a song
I gave ben stiller this watch when we
wrapped Tropic Thunder he said it's too
big for me and gave it back to me and I
have not spoken any sense that's a lie
Ben Stiller gave me this watch when we
wrapped Tropic Thunder last and
certainly not least that's a Patek
Phillipe my missus got me this watch I'd
say this is easily the most glamourous
watch man can have when she first gave
it to me I said did you get me a Seiko
what is this it's my birthday but I've
grown over time to realize that it is an
extremely classy and desirable watch and
also I did not want to incur her wrath
by talking [ __ ] about a Patek Phillipe
because this isn't extremely fine watch
for watching
old friend
I'm wearing a lovely Patek Phillipe